the least interesting thing I talk about
all day is being pregnant you know
gaining weight and having all these
changes in my body I would probably
forget about it while she might want to
forget about it Meghan McCain says the
world keeps reminding her about
postpartum pounds having a child is the
greatest thing I've ever done I love it
so much just four weeks after giving
birth to her youngest daughter Clover
Megan's apparently been flooded with
questions about shedding the lbs She
lays it all out in a new column for the
Daily Mail claiming she's been offered
injections to quote melt the pounds away
the US is seeing a rise in the
popularity of weight loss drugs like
ozympic and wagovi yeah those are two of
the brand names for semaglutite the
medication Megan is referencing it was
designed to help manage type 2 diabetes
but it's also been approved to treat
obesity turning it into a fat drug of
sorts in Hollywood circles I have a
semiglutide well so my doctor my
anti-aging doctor just hands it out to
anybody right oh and obviously now I
can't say her name but she I I didn't
even know I was on it Megan says I'm
told everyone is doing it as if that was
ever a compelling case I hear just take
the shot as it has become known in
shorthand she goes on to claim she'd
been offered the shot on the black
market AKA not through a doctor with one
acquaintance even suggesting she use
extra shots they have lying around at
home but Megan's making it clear she's
refused it in any form I kind of wanted
to just be as much as I can part of the
solution instead of the problem there's
a clear moral issue here I would rather
have a few extra pounds than shoot my
self up with medicine wigobi has a
higher dose of the same active
ingredient used in a diabetes drug
called ozempe
which is not approved for weight loss
both are so popular some doses are in
short supply troubling for people using
ozepik to treat diabetes
while Megan wants to leave semi-glue
tied to those who legitimately need it
she's also turning it down in order to
set an example for her children because
they will one day face the same beauty
standards I'm really been thinking about
my mortality and what I want to do with
my life and what I want my life to look
like and
being in a more positive space is is a
big is a big part of that
Megan and her hubby Ben Dominic now have
two little girls at home I don't know if
you have children like having a daughter
in particular because I love strong
women and I feel like my parents raised
me to be such a strong woman like having
a daughter that I have this
responsibility to like obviously love
and nurture in 2020 the couple welcomed
Liberty we need to be positive role
models for my little sister and woman
that come after me not everyone's going
to be a size zero and I'm not an actress
I'm not a model I'm happy and
comfortable in my skin and I have no
idea why anyone would care how much I
weigh and I just want to be a positive
role model of my little sister
foreign
[Music]